il ya un truc karim en france une
nouvelle émission je voulais absolument
ou la motrice
ça s'appelle naked attraction way est ce
que vous l'avez vu c'est le concept est
simple des candidats à la recherche de
l'amour se met à nu est d'ailleurs tenu
mais seront choisis que sur un seul
critère leur corps c'est à dire que nous
ici on peut rester huit ans imaginons
soirée nous et ça veut dire frères c'est
pas on n'est pas choisi pourrait inciter
ttk une catastrophe
leurs visages ne sera libéré dès n'est
qu'à la fin disponible en version
floutés sur six pay en journée tout est
visible à 22h30 sur le site de la chaîne
et ça va arriver je crois que m6 veulent
père c'est fort est ce que vous aimez
cette émission est ce que vous avez
envie de la voir ce que nous avons envie
d'y participer
aw alpes à walla le zigouiller le zig
uni a l'air le gigot n'y allèrent elle
sait que vous demandez déjà retrouvé
deux ans si c'est nice 6 mois je
commence à le regretter
découvrons ce que les femmes et les
hommes trouvent réellement attirant
c'est sympathique
est ce que choisir un partenaire
uniquement sur le physique
peut mieux faire permettra de trouver le
bon je suis est simplement parfait nous
le saurons dans cette émission tu vas tu
choisir you take que la décision la plus
dure de ma vie et oui alors qui a envie
de voir cette émission et bjr nul les
égouts ni non moi je déteste les
émissions se sert d'un prétexte bidon
juste pour voir des gens à poil en fait
au début oui dans notre société
matérialiste les vêtements comporte nous
empêche de montrer qui on est vraiment
en fait tu voulais juste montrer des
gens et non ça me rappelle les enjeux
ont fait croire qu'ils sont à miami pour
trouver du travail
est-ce que vous avez est ce que vous
seriez capable ou de choisir un homme
juste sur son site vous fait débat une
pomme juste juste sur son île gujarat
banon non un sexe qu'un sexe non moi
vraiment requis d'un tout c'est vrai moi
je pense qu'il faut arrêter d'être
saveur du temps avant de voir le gigot
ni de votre nom quelques quelques jours
dans quelques mois quelques mois à bath
11 igualada part du programme
c'est lorsque les candidates découvrent
leurs prétendants et découvre surtout
leurs égouts dit la partie inférieure
des corps accroche-toi rebecca je
m'accroche
ah ouais pourquoi premières impressions
je suis directement attiré par jaune ils
sont venus à une bonne taille
c'est très bien fait sens là ça y est
importante
oui je dois dire qu'il ya un truc avec
verre tu peux te rapprocher
ok allons-y allons inspecter inspectant
la marchandise ils étaient franchement
mieux de loin barbet alors déjà cette
émission elle arrivera jamais en france
ici
tunisie déjà oui mais sur ces scores j'y
crois moyen je sais pas ça être fait par
et j'y crois moyen je savais personnes
qui ont mais non sur ce plateau vous
n'êtes qu'une bande d'hypocrites c'est
vrai les égouts ni la bière famille oui
mais voilà ce qu'a dit d'accord vous
avez vu vous vous avez vu au bout de
combien de temps le second niveau votre
bon sens
on s'est séparé de deux semaines ce
cheval vous avez choisi cui est d'accord
je suis d'accord elle dit que c'est pas
important la taille du sexe et ou
franchement qu'ils soient comme ça il
faut pas non plus qu'il soit comme ça
c'est pas vrai ah oui ça m'arrive mais
avant de vous avez vu coincer goût ni un
micro vraiment à mes produits goût dit
que j'avais très mal au coeur pour lui
quoi c'est clair que va faire amis mais
ça arrive c'est à dire oui il faut
savoir s'en servir faut savoir s'en
servir mais là avec repas de l'émission
moi je trouve que c'est il est réaliste
de quoi d'avoir des égaux ni non mais
c'est irréaliste comme émissions et et
je trouve que ça ça nous change les
idées oui moi je trouve pas besoin de
rire en ce moment avec le confinement et
qu'est ce qui marche dans la vie eh ben
c'est la bouffe et le cul je suis désolé
que ça bien écoutez c'est bien l'odeur
du peuple élu moi ce que j'aime c'est la
franchise de nathalie marquay voilà oui
mais vous rendez compte des valeurs que
ça renvoie ya plein de jeunes qui
regardent ça la première chose qu'on
monte chez quelqu'un qu'on va rencontrer
denis fauque rionnais médaille tant que
les hypocrites gelé mais leur corps et
ses esprits est ce que tu as un gros
sexe etc
ça crée des complexes et les autres
actions mais c'est quoi c'est jérôme m6
1 s'en fout sixième alors bas des jeunes
on a laissé pas défoncer le programme
sam et 30 secondes des français j'ai pas
besoin de le défense et je suis quand
même d'accord avec guillaume pannaud
années 90 quand idiot mais pas par les
voilà que vous voulez bien oui
effectivement c'est plus à même de dire
venez regarder des cures grigoli
ensemble desigual le devant et le
derrière la face et la fesse regardons
ça ensemble c'est oui pas besoin de
trouver un prétexte
intellect le concours pour justifier ça
et maintenant je trouve que c'est un
programme qui sera sans doute plutôt
triste que fort is an maintenant je
regarderai parce que c'est mon boulot de
regarder alors là tu gilbert belge s'est
pas du tout d'accord avec guillaume sur
les agonies mais oui bien sûr moi j'ai
regardé l'émission c'est vraiment l'âme
qui se reflète à travers
il faut tout regarder il faut tout
regarder et moi je regrette qu'on ne
voit pas le visage mais après les gens'
dévoisé le comté ont choisi on choisit
un zegoulli parce qu'il appartient à une
âme
merci l'école a plané coop a écouté
moteur j'ai trouvé ça très drôle léger
et puis ça va au delà juste du physique
puisqu'il ya pas mal d change assez
marrant qui sont faits avec les
candidats on voyait déjà la femme est
très drôle et très marquée ce convoi
avant le visage et le sexe bien
évidemment de quoi vous que sexy ni non
[Musique]
moi ce qui me plaît pas en fait dans ce
que tu dis gilles malgré tout c'est que
si c'est les igg uni ça va pour toi si
on y avait vu la villette
eh bien on me dit que c'était vrai que
c'est vrai mais il ya aussi juste il a
raison car ajouté quand même si opel un
truc à manger un truc a énormément
démission dating qui ont été développées
genre une centaine ont quand même dans
le monde et elles se sont toutes les
plantes et la tête là c'est sainte être
c'est un peu audacieux de la part des
six mais peut-être que ça va être enfin
le dating qui va marcher car sa grâce
aux aiguillonnais et grâce aux six
candidats